[Music]
upon emerging from stasis ethic is the
unfortunate recipient of three surprises
the first a prison cell
the second complete amnesia and the
third a mysterious stranger has gotten
stuck squeezing through the bars on her
window his name is hedge and he has come
to help ethics save the world but first
they have to break out of jail hedge
turns his hand into a lockpick and
outlines the challenge ahead each lock
in the prison works in the same unusual
way inside the keyhole is a red dial
that can be rotated to one of 100
positions numbered 1 through 100 the key
for a given cell spins the dial to the
right position which when stopped there
makes it turn green and unlocks the door
it would be out of the question to steal
keys from a guard but hedge has a better
idea
Hedge can carry how ethics commands if
ethic tells him to walk five steps
forward turn right then walk another
five steps that's exactly what he'll do
hedge needs specific instructions though
if ethics says pick the lock or try
every combination that would be too
vague but spin the dial five positions
forward would work once out of the cell
they will only have a few moments to
crack the lock for the outer prison door
two before the guards catch them so what
instructions will allow hedge to
efficiently open any door pause now to
figure it out for yourself before we
explain the solution here's a hint a key
programming concept that can help unlock
the door is called
a loop this can be one or more
instructions that hedge will iterate or
repeat a specified number of times like
jump up and down 100 times or an
instruction that hedge will repeat until
a condition is met such as keep jumping
up and down until it's 7 o'clock
[Music]
the first thing that's clear is that you
need to find a way for hedge to try
every combination until one works
what takes a little more effort is how
exactly you do so one solution would be
to instruct hedge to try every
combination in succession try one and
check the light if it turns green open
the door and if not try to if that
doesn't work try three all the way up to
100 but it would be tedious to lay that
out in its entirety why right more than
100 lines of code when you can do the
same thing with just 3 this is where a
loop comes in there are a few ways to go
about this the lock has 100 positions so
ethic could say check the dials color
then spin the dial forward once for 100
repetitions remember where the dial
turns green then have hedge set it back
to that number a loop like this where
you specify the number of times it
repeats is called a for loop but an even
more efficient loop would have hedge
spin the dial one position at a time
until it turns green and as soon as that
happens have him stop and open the door
that way if the door unlocks on one he
doesn't need to cycle through all the
rest of the numbers this is an until
loop
because it involves doing an action
until a condition is met a similar
alternate approach would be to turn the
dial while it's still red then stop
that's called a while loop back to the
adventure hedge loops through the
combinations and the cell opens at 41
ethic and hedge wait until the perfect
moment in the guards rotation and make a
break for it soon ethic faces a choice
hide inside a mysterious crystal or try
to crack the outer door and make a run
for it
ethic chooses to run the second door
takes hedge longer requiring him to spin
all the way to 93 but he gets it open
[Music]
and takes the opportunity to explain why
he's rescued ethic the world is in
turmoil robots have taken over and only
ethic can set things right in order to
do so they'll need to collect three
powerful artifacts that are being used
for nefarious purposes across the land
only then can ethic return to the world
machine that giant crystal to set things
right
[Music]
ethic may have escaped the prison but
what has she gotten herself into
continue the adventure in the next
episode of think like a coder and don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]
you